[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos wünscht ihnen viel vergnügen
wir stärken uns für das neue jahren sind
heute an einem ort der uns frische
energie verspricht ja in diesen zeiten
suchen viele menschen zuversicht in der
spirituellen welt wir lassen uns darauf
ein und berichten von hier aus auch über
projekte die konstruktiv mit der korona
realitäten gut und hoffnung das sind
zentrale themen heute warum
[Musik]
wir kommen auf den kulturplatz wir
tanken heute kraft und machen station in
der emma kunz korte im aargauischen
würenlos die künstlerin und heilerin
entdeckte 1 diesen ort und wünschte sich
dass daraus ein kulturelles und
geistiges zentrum werden möge ja und all
dies ist heute genauso die werke von
einem malkurs werden hier gezeigt und
hier können wir auch in die stille
kommen
[Musik]
das herzstück des zentrums ist die
felsengrotte hier können wir körper und
geist neu aufladen
dieser gedanke gefällt mir gerade zu
jahresbeginn besonders gut wie die
tatsache dass die realität mit corona
auch kreative kräfte freisetzen kann
und das beweist etwa dieses buch eine
pandemische weltschau in karikaturen
zeichnerinnen und zeichner aus über 50
ländern kommentieren das zeitgeschehen
portiert kritisch und mit humor wir uns
von diesem witz wollen wir uns in dieser
sendung immer wieder anstecken lassen
[Musik]
die mächtige felsengrotte ist ein
geeigneter ort für kleine fluchten aus
dem alltag
[Musik]
wer möchte kann diesen ort auch für
einen moment ganz für sich alleine haben
die gott er ist für die öffentlichkeit
zugänglich
[Musik]
ja wir alle gehen unterschiedlich mit
der korona realität viele hadern einige
verzweifeln und wieder andere finden
mitten in der krise neue horizonte den
kulturschaffenden kommt in diesen zeiten
eine dokumentarische funktion zu umso
bemerkenswerter weil sie dabei einen
kreativen umgang finden so sieht sein
arbeitsalltag normalerweise aus kriegs
und krisengebieten in kongo seit der
pandemie setzt dominic nahr in der
schweiz fest anstatt in krisengebiete
fährt er jetzt immer wieder ins
appenzell wo er herkommt und
fotografiert das drama der natur
ich glaube dass sturm ich gerade heftig
lüftet die scharte sind auf dem foto
wolke und so nicht und so wiederholen
sich wirklich dramatisch vom
kriegsgebiet in die natur eine krise
zwingt den krisen fotografen in den
albtraum
[Musik]
ich fotografiere krisengebiet tipper 21
geht in 221 g und non stop for iraq bis
afghanistan somalia kongo wenn nicht
zwei stunden quasi alles klar oder
fotografiert und da müsse sich bewegen
und apple game jahren immer mehr still
still sie und irgendwie irgendwo anders
reisen
stillstand herrscht auch im
schauspielhaus zürich
der saal ist leer das theater bleibt zu
doch direktor nicolas stemann hat wegen
corona ein ereignisreiches jahr hinter
sich
ja das ist ja das paradoxe also ich als
theaterleiter fand es wahnsinnig
anstrengend als künstler war das für
mich eine sehr produktive zeit also das
ist ein dankbares thema weil es ja auch
so viele menschen angeht es gibt es ja
selten dass ein thema so kollektiv alle
betrifft und dass man auf einmal von
individuellen erfahrung sprechen kann
die tatsächlich jetzt mal in der zeit
für sehr viele menschen gelten hallo
hallo ich sehe dich gar nicht aber ich
kann nicht würdig also ich höre ich gut
ich würde ich suche du musst dein bild
an machen kannst um stimmen hat im
lockdown mit seinem ensemble videoclips
produziert es sind frittierte kommentare
zum umgang mit der situation
[Musik]
es war schön
auf wieder
also so ein lock down ist ja erstmal
nicht wirtschafts logisch sondern das
hat andere gründe
und auf einmal hatten andere dinge wie
zum beispiel sicherheit und gesundheit
priorität vor profit orientiert hat
das hielt nicht lange an also irgendwann
ging es natürlich dann doch darum wie
retten wir die wirtschaft und dieser
kleine moment aber wo man merkt es gibt
ein anderes primat der war wertvoll
[Musik]
stemann hat diesen wertvollen moment
zwischen hoffnung und verzweiflung
sobald es die pandemie erlaubte auf die
bühne gebracht
das ist alles nur noch
[Musik]
das ist alles nicht mehr auf
neben dem theater haben auch schweizer
filmschaffende die neue realität der
pandemie kreativ umgesetzt
so besuchte regisseurin bettina oberli
eine coiffeuse im altersheim ein
dokumentarfilm begleitet den samichlaus
bei seinen virtuellen weihnachts
besuchen und der film nachts nicht
tanzen
das wird die sehnsucht der jugend nach
nächtlicher bewegung
[Musik]
auch für dominic nahr wird bald klar er
muss die krise im eigenen land
festhalten wenn auch keinen krieg
er beginnt an den rändern der
gesellschaft zu fotografieren
etwa in zürich sie begreift letzte und
lang schwarz mit der bombe erst losgeht
und wenn es kritisch wird denn schlechte
krass alle sind fokussiert und erste
woche und was immer geben und sie haben
ja okay und raubt fort und alles ok also
zum fotografiert werde sich irgend so
eine notsituation in vielen gegenden
zeige dass das eine gurke virus virus
hahaha wir sind schließlich auch noch da
das theater bedient sich gekonnt bei
verschwörungstheoretikern und
kommentiert die neue form der
wirtschaftspolitik die lufthansa bekommt
9 milliarden vom staat in aussicht
gestellt
die frage damals wie kommen wir jetzt an
dieser 9 milliarden hier an
naja die lufthansa ist ja die
muttergesellschaft von der swiss ich
habe ja auch nur deutsche mutter geht
auch eine rente vom staat wenn auch
nicht so groß aber bei so viel
gemeinsamkeit heute man doch gleich mit
kollaborieren
wir würden dann auch das dach vom zaun
abbauen wenn das was hilft heimatschutz
und denkmalschutz hätten das sicher
nichts dagegen
und dann kann man in gecharterten
maschinen über den frauen schweben und
aus sicherer distanz theatergruppe was
ist eigentlich wichtiger wird im
zweifelsfall die die waffenfabrik
gerettet oder das theater und man ahnt
dass es nicht das theater ist was der
priorität hat in dieser form der ja
irgendwie finanziellen triage aber das
ist natürlich nicht schön und jetzt
nicht nur für uns nicht schön
tatsächlich für eine gesellschaft die
sich dann doch auch irgendwann fragen
muss
auf welcher basis findet das eigentlich
alles statt
wenn dann doch auch solche
traditionellen institutionen wie unsere
leichtfertig preisgegeben werden noch
wird die kultur gestützt doch die
herausforderung wird sein in einer
fortwährenden krise nicht nur über
arbeitsplätze sondern über inhalte reden
zu können
eigens für das wert ist sehr
interessantes sehr angespannte szene zu
entziehen
dadurch dass schon so was wie masken
tragen zu einer solchen zerrüttung der
gesellschaft geführt hat bin ich jetzt
nicht allzu hoffnungsfroh dass man diese
ämter einigermaßen zivilisiert wird
führen können da hoffen wir mal dass es
keine ganz ausweglose tragödie wird
[Musik]
die aargauerin emma kunz lebte von 1892
bis 19 63 und war bereits in ihren
jungen jahren bekannt als
heilpraktikerin
sie arbeitete unter anderem mit dem
pendel das pendel wurde in späteren
jahren auch zum instrument für ihr
künstlerisches schaffen
sie kreierte hunderte von großformatigen
bildern auf millimeterpapier hier im
emma kunz zentrum sind ihre wichtigsten
werke permanent zu sehen
das gesamtwerk von emma kunz wird immer
wieder im in- und im ausland gezeigt ab
dem 23 januar auch im kunsthaus in aarau
ja und da immer kunstzentrum knabberte
großer treffe ich jetzt klar intrakey
sie kümmert sich ums leben zwölf oder
evergreens er sehr außergewöhnliche frau
ich sie was weiß man über das schaffen
der mann kurz vor allem energetisch
geschaffen und mit hand und fliegt mit
pendel hat sie geschafft und mit dem bus
steigt wo sie dort einen der großen
entdeckt hat wo sie braucht hat für
jegliche beschwerdebilder für römer
beschwerdeführer noch übrig für
verletzungen
verstöße gequatsche über ganz einfach
insektenstich und aus dankbarkeit ist
dass emma kunz zentrum entstand exakt
also sie hat sich gewünscht dass er dem
ort wie sie sollen spezielle kraftakt
ist für sie aber nur die strahlkraft
hatte ort dass man muss zugänglich
machen und so hat sie sich mit der
begegnungsstätte eigenschaft kulturelles
geistigen teil ich hoffe sich vereinen
als brandlöscher aus ihrem
künstlerischen schaffen da vorgegangen
damit so werke hat videos und der ist
italien über uns die meditationen und
hat eine spur
es ist das jahr der pandas sind sodass
praxis aber fertig alle halbe milliarde
pendler und eine silberkugel abhandeln
und hatten das papier schweizer mit dem
jahr der handel hat sie denn genau
gewusst
spanplatten anzeigt wo sie muss punkt
setzte mit dem bleistift hat das nur 15
teams man sich vorstellen das ganze
papier ist nur von der clean abhängig
sie hat sich linear genannt hat genau
ist welle punkt dass sie unternimmt muss
verbinden das ebenso geometrische
strukturen helfen
obwohl sie sich selber nicht aus
künstlerin gesehen hat wird ihre
fähigkeit wieder großes gestellt die
zwei wochen ein kunstschuss euro ganz
viele werke der emma kunz wo einen
kontext zu jungen kunststoffe wäre zeigt
wer ist dieser frage vom aktuellen
zeitgeist dass man das aufnimmt und sich
inspirieren
absolut ich glaube die spiritualität ist
sehr gefragt und inspiriert natürlich
auch junge künstler zeitgenössische
künstler bis 17 und thema kunz
eigentlich als inspirationsquellen und
es ist ja so dass man sieht der nabu
viele mannschaften sichtlich mehr
bedürfnis nach spiritualität erlebt
sieht das aus auch mit mannschaften
immer man wie zu normalen sind es können
menschen mit roten und ist zentrum ist
man sehen muss ja bilder der für die
orgel
es ist ein uhr ort und ein rückzugsort
dass sie wirklich für sie können sie um
die profile kanzlerin andere sitten
plötzlich auf dass gerade in cannes
entlang
mit
die
ist ein paar tausend
durch
si
nein
[Musik]
kultur in zeiten von corona damit setzt
sich auch das projekt pay-per-view
auseinander pepe juwel kunstschaffenden
helfen damit ihre arbeiten sichtbar
bleiben auch in der krise und zwar mit
einer ausgeklügelten idee ein weiterer
siegerprojekt aus unserem kulturkreis
bewerb
[Musik]
so hat das projekt duo die jury von
seiner idee überzeugt kunstwerke aus
verschiedenen landesteilen als blickfang
auf plakaten im öffentlichen raum eine
aufgabe die beide das ganze jahr
beschäftigen wird ich heiße sophie
benvenuti und bin selbstständige
illustratorin name ist völlig offen die
uci war eine idee des projekts ist die
deutsch und die französisch sprachigen
regionen der schweiz zu verbinden
werning städte des röstigrabens wie zb
die hendrix und damit trennt das für
kultur schaffen die tz sehr wichtig ist
trotzdem ein großer outputs generiere
und dass man ein publikum zu
präsentieren
einstweilen gruppen sie noch ihr eigenes
logo bald werden es aber die plakate im
rahmen von paypal user künstlerinnen und
künstler aus dem kanton st gallen waadt
und bern schickten ihnen ihre skizzen 36
haben sie ausgewählt
jeden monat heimat für grundsteuer oder
kunst und erzähle ich dass sie ist
einfach zu süß und natürlich da glaubt
dass die 33 einfach gleichzeitig mit
zwei grundfarben geben sie für jeden
monat vor die kunstwerke sind noch in
arbeit als plakate werden sie dann in st
gallen und wilde hängen
nein
das netzwerk von der künstlerin und
instabil so oder so größer seien
galaxien sternen und galaxien stoff
indes durchaus interessant marsberg im
öffentlichen raum für weitere zeugen
kennengelernt haben sich die zwei in
kunst studium an der hochschule luzern
und siebdruck kurs seither sind sie ein
paar
erst als sie aus dem weg er spricht kaum
französisch sie hat schnell seine
dialekt angenommen mega transparenz
zwischendrin im biwak paradies b haben
die beiden an atelier gefunden dass sie
mit der grafikerin diotima groß hat
nutzen
immer dabei der elf wochen alte boston
terrier welpen ruby und sich nach
letzten
[Applaus]
im atelier finden ab und zu performances
statt und es werden tattoos angebracht
ein offener ort für alle die die
infrastruktur nutzen möchten hier
bespricht bin minute den tor für eine
transparente hülle mit aufdruck zum
neuen deal album einer band aus freiburg
ein kleiner auftrag aber wichtig fürs
vorankommen
ich sehe mich als unterstützerin sie
bringen viele ideen mit
aber ich kann abschätzen was es noch
dazu braucht ob es so machbar ist
die beiden haben sich auf ein altes
kunsthandwerk spezialisiert den
siebdruck eine liebhaberei die sie mit
viel wagemut in angriff genommen haben
all die großgeräte konnten sie vier grad
nachts 1000 franken auf einer
verkaufsplattform erstehen
darauf werden die plakate für preview
entstehen da ich dachte so viele dinge
für alles mache und es ist so billig
dass mir nachher auftrag hinzu
wir glauben dass beide dieses recht ist
das ersparte drehen aber manchmal hätte
da damit trainieren bereits gemacht oder
das auto ließ oder seite posten
das kann auch interessant hierbei ist ja
es ist cool dass mich dies mache und
auch dann mit der ppp projekts damit
andere lübz andere künstlerinnen und
künstler schaffen und sichern da freu
mich ja
vom atelier aus in die innenstadt ende
januar sollen hier die ersten von
künstlerinnen und künstlern gestalteten
plakaten zu sehen sein
an speziellen für die kultur
reservierten plakat zeigt mit wie viel
aufmerksamkeit dürfen sie der rechnen
und wie wappnen sie sich gegen
vandalismus
kommen sie vorbei da ich habe schon
stehen die straße
[Musik]
bild wo modernen kreationen sind die
ordner betrifft drücken
das ganze jahr zieht
geschafft
dabei
[Musik]
ja
nein
[Musik]
ja der tag weicht dem abend und die
große erscheint im allerschönsten licht
das kann man auch von der figur des
dandys behaupten seine kernkompetenz ist
das mit eleganz und grandezza das leben
zu feiern
in der kunsthalle bern wäre aktuell noch
eine ausstellung zu den dandys dieser
welt zu sehen leider muss diese
pausieren
eine besondere form des denn die teams
zelebrieren die suppe in den armen
vierteln des kongos sagen sie sich jetzt
erst recht so denn die nova schaut heim
auf dem wohl ungewöhnlichsten darauf
steg afrikas der richtige auftritt ist
ihr leben
sie sind keine models sondern ladies und
gentlemen des kongo stilbewusst
exzentrisch mann ist in einem
slumviertel aber plötzlich siehst du
jemanden der sich wie ein millionär
kleidet jackett von kent zu krawatte von
geld oder 500 oder 1000 dollar schuhe
aus krokodilleder
couture in den armenviertel von kinshasa
oder brazzaville dieser werden gefeiert
für ihr ausgeprägtes stilbewusstsein
ihre art sich zu bewegen
tagsüber taxifahrer oder arbeiterinnen
nach feierabend legen sie feines tuch an
je teurer desto besser
dafür steht für solid edison bios led
bessern elegant gesellschaft der
stimmungsmacher und eleganten personen
eine einzigartige subkultur des kongo
[Musik]
die beste art rockstar zu sein ist wenn
du wie ein rockstar aussiehst und dich
wie einer bewegt aber das alles auf eine
freundliche art
der betrieb sei die ist nicht der erste
den dieser per interessieren
doch kaum jemand begleitete sie so
hartnäckig wie der preisgekrönte
fotograf über drei jahre lang reist er
immer wieder in den kongo
selbstbehauptung durchs ziel dieser
bewegung entstand in den 1920 er jahren
als antwort auf die kolonialherrschaft
junge kongo lesen wollten sich besser
kleiden als die französischen oder
belgischen kolonialherren
das verleiht würde bis heute trotzen sie
dem elend ihrer lebensbedingungen waren
die form eine stunde arbeit im kongo und
ich sehe so aus sei die schaute auch in
die kleiderschränke der suppe für einen
designer anzug sparen sie oft jahrelang
bei einem durchschnittslohn im kongo von
900 dollar pro jahr und kultur
internationaler marken kombinieren sie
mit eigenen entwürfen sind also selbst
kreierte ich wollte sie nicht als objekt
auf einer parkbank oder einem schönen
platz inszenieren
ich wollte verstehen wo und wie sie
leben wie sie es schaffen geld zu sparen
wie ihre nachbarschaft auf sie reagiert
ich habe nie weiter als 500 meter
außerhalb ihres zuhauses fotografiert
sei dies kommentierte fotoband der
kürzlich erschienen ist zeigt dies ab
und sind weit mehr als fashionistas sie
glänzen durch improvisationstalent und
sind trotz widriger umstände herr und
herrin ihres schicksals
dafür werden sie geliebt
[Musik]
die art wie sie die kleidung wählen wie
kreativ sie sind was von ihrer
persönlichkeit in den stil mit einfließt
dinge zu kombinieren die man ansonsten
nie kombinieren würde ihre würde
die elegante und ihre philosophie eines
friedlichen harmonischen zusammenlebens
das alles macht für mich einen zettel
der teufel trägt vielleicht prada 18
mehr daraus im kongo wird gern der satz
zitiert weiße menschen erfanden diese
kleidung aber wir haben kunst aus ihr
gemacht
wir verabschieden uns hier von diesem
magischen ort die emma kunz graute bei
würenlos eine reise hierhin kam ich
wärmstens empfehlen ja um nächste woche
da reißen wir zu den sternen und zwar
mit der astrologin alexandra kruse
ich freue mich wenn sie dann auch wieder
mit dabei sind gleich jetzt geht's
weiter auf sf1 mit der serie meine
geniale frauen den nach dem roman von
elena verrannte bis bald und musik
[Musik]
auf dem rücken
note 4
mehr
[Musik]
immer
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen mehr kultur
swisslos